incrementa la tensión tras las
concertinas de alambres la cada vez más
militarizada frontera polaca con belarús
donde miles de migrantes y refugiados en
su mayoría procedentes de medio oriente
están atrapados en territorio bielorruso
a la espera de poder cruzar a la unión
europea
22 por minsk los migrantes esperaban un
fácil cruce ilegal de la frontera polaca
la ayuda de activistas y un viaje
exitoso a occidente nada de eso sucederá
nuestra frontera está sellada y el apoyo
de la comunidad internacional a las
acciones de las autoridades polacas está
creciendo polonia está sacando músculo
en materia militar y se niega a permitir
la entrada de estas personas la unión
europea acusa a ming de orquestar lo que
califica como un ataque híbrido para
presionar al bloque europeo por las
recientes sanciones impuestas al
gobierno del mandatario alexander
lukashenko pero belarrús niega
rotundamente las acusaciones el lunes
bruselas prevé adoptar un nuevo marco
legal que permitirá imponer sanciones
adicionales
hablé con mackay el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de belarús para plantear la
precaria situación humanitaria en la
frontera con la unión europea se debe
proteger la vida de las personas y
permitir el acceso de las agencias
humanitarias
la situación actual es inaceptable y
debe detenerse las personas no deben
usarse como armas previa que se aprueben
los castigos los representantes de
exteriores de belarús y la unión europea
discutieron la crisis migratoria por vía
telefónica ming se advirtió que más
sanciones resultarán contraproducentes
mientras tanto en la frontera se vive
una verdadera crisis humanitaria a
medida que las temperaturas caen por
debajo del punto de congelación y las
organizaciones de derechos humanos están
a una desescalada para ayudar a los
migrantes entre los que hay mujeres
embarazadas y niños